chiche
j'ai vu
que j'essaie de donner à chaque fois je
vais essayer de
nous faire part de ses enseignements que
j'ai des formules moi même et j'ai des
escales à
ce qui provient de l'expérience minutes
l'anglais
je commence
je verrai pour lire ce que j'ai ici
après jouer demain donc je vais vous
dire premièrement que la obtient onu
après la civilisation à la vie
pourquoi j'ai pourquoi j'ai écrit cette
phrase j'ai écrit cette phrase parce que
j'entends souvent les joueurs vous faire
trop échanges
sur le nez des demandes je voulais juste
parler colombie en compte
nul après la civilisation elle
ne pas subir le contexte de naissance se
prendre l'alternative pour un point de
chute à escalader
un territoire à explorer un bel m a
dépassé
si je vous dis ça c'est parce que vous
entendez souvent un discours néo
patriotique qui en train de faire de
l'appartenance aux dérives alain ferrand
soit il faut savoir ce que vous faites
de ce territoire nouvelle dans ce
territoire et donc pas se satisfaire de
fête du feu didier trenet
et comment vous ne dépassez les simples
la troisième chose qui voulez vous dire
ce que parler les langues du monde elle
a retrouvé la poésie du magen avant de
naissance
mais approprié la loma ta langue
maternelle
l'hiver en énergie pour une meilleure
année ans
cette troisième phrase mérite d'inspirer
de mon expérience personnelle
parce que j'ai été pendant cinq ans
rédacteur en chef vétérinaire
et lorsque j'étais à tenter de dérider
je disais quand une autre course et ce
dès 2001 2006 et à l'épaule je disais
toujours à l'équipe autour écoutez en
français après j'ai convaincu
il faudrait lancer tout cela la lente
et c'est de là qu'est venu erik une
expérience michel rouger 25
personnellement
et je les ai lancé avec l'idée que nous
devions écrire en arabe mais que
sociologiquement nous devons être prêts
là d'elijah qui est la langue maroni
et ça je suis très heureux aujourd'hui
de voir tous les sorts cas la question
de négligeable dans la société
et personnellement j'ai continué cette
expérience d'intelligent essentiellement
par le terrain parce que je suis d'abord
en guerre depuis plus de 20 ans et
l'expérience dans le théâtre le montre
une chose fondamentale
nous entendons souvent parler de damas
théâtre je suis parmi les fondateurs
comme un théâtre c'est tout simplement
permettre à des gens de jouer dans la
langue de normes à l'ordre naturel
des choses qui parle est aujourd'hui
béchir et de se distraire en même temps
à se distraire unique qu'on réfléchisse
et se distraire mais quand les acteurs
jouent dans la langue maternelle
qu'est ce qui se passe il se passe
quelque chose d'organique qui se passe
il ya une énergie qui se déploie qui est
extraordinaire qui dans les échanges
entre la scène et la salle et c'est
cette énergie là qui provient du corps
qui provient la scène du bois lorsque la
scène c'est lui moi et qui premières
proviennent de projecteur la lumière et
qui provient de l' échange les deux
espaces c'est ça qui donne la forme
soutient mais sans le fait ça se passe
dans la langue maternelle
il y aurait 7 9 ans
je
alors quand tu te trouve au milieu des
autres tu as le choix entre
deux voire unique et lue par me éric
frier seul dans ce chemin en prenant les
autres de haut en cherchant d'abord on
bien
croire à la multitude
donc ça c'est le deuxième joint coin la
multitude des projets au milieu de tout
ça c'est une qualité sans jamais oublier
l'homme se construit d'abord par le lian
cette différence entre le bien et le
lien
je voulais qu'elle m'envoie un lointain
monastère
personnel
dans un choix que j'ai dû faire un
moment
et qui on voit aussi est-ce que j'étais
au départ c'est que tant il est en
vérité quand l'expérience de michel a
tourné court est l'outil peut alors
parler la langue le creux de la vague
j'ai eu une autre repartir aux
etats-unis
et pour aller dans une université masi
et j'ai refusé
parce que ça c'est le mien personnel
c'était là trajet par hambourg -
uniquement
qu'est ce qui m'a poussé à refuser cette
offre
et je respecte tous ceux qui ont fait le
chemin inverse je ne te prie je ne
détiens pas la vérité je ne fais que
partager une expérience
j'ai fait ce choix
parce que moi je suis j'ai voulu rester
avec le choix d'être ici et de faire si
en lien avec les gens avec lesquels je
suis et faire le choix de rester c'est
ça la faiblesse à force que très peu
entraîné heureusement dans ce cri parce
que beaucoup de gens restent en sang
martin le coach en grèce en ayant la
tête ailleurs en étant connecté beaucoup
de gens restent aussi lors de nos d'être
pris pour la somme d'un fait pour
prouver sa
rendre la tête d'être ici donc moi
personnellement c'est le mieux c'est le
vivre ensemble qui m'a fait qui a fait
que je voulais rester mais restait en
restant critique rester en étant
toujours vigilant au respect tout en
ayant ce souci de construire avec les
autres une meilleur niveau
il ya deux armes qui s'offre à toi sur
le chemin de la vie
la lame généalogie
qui est un trop grand ce crâne qui
votera ce n'est origines au masculin et
c'est la réconforter mon héritage il est
rassurant
griscelli mais ce que le pronom
situe le prolongement bel 20 ans que tu
es enfant tu
il ya un autre c'est l'art de la
filiation d'esprit il démentira
retrouver dans le pacifique et leur
enfoncer ni linéaire ni prédéfinis il ta
vie par association à creuser le sillon
de la vocation
est constamment l'origine il est parti
mercredi
c'est par là ce deuxième je n'ai
rencontré
au moment où j'ai démissionné de la
presse
écrite
et que je discutais avec un ami qui m'a
cité jacques beck
c'est jacques maire qui dit il faut
savoir renforcer son poids ce
qu'est ce que cela veut dire en français
sont possibles ça veut dire ça ça vient
d'une tradition mystique
qui dit que nos deux clients nous sommes
tous rattachés à une branche d'un arbre
de filiation d'esprit mais nous
passerons nous pouvons passer toute
votre vie sans savoir à quelle branche
nous sommes rattachés et sans savoir
qu'est ce qui fait notre force
intérieure
personnellement j'ai compris que ma
force intérieure lui donnant la culture
les deux dans la recherche c'est pour ça
que j'ai redéfini ce que j'étais en
train de
renforcer son repas spécifiques pour une
gens passent beaucoup de passeport ou de
l'otan tout en or mais ce lundi il a dit
nation dans le travail la passion au
mieux tu es en symbiose avec angoisse
visite
alors
s'accrocher avait dit dans la vie
c'est croire comme durant
avoir de certitude que lorsque tu
touches du congrès
savoir que temps meilleurs m c'est le
chemin la destinée
renner dans son petit chose qui est mal
le cours de la vie tel est lé plus grand
qu au dernier l'autre
faire attention aux petites choses
donner le maximum de temps et de rigueur
aux petites choses dans l'instant vous
êtes en ce moment difficile que vous
regardez dans la photo vous permet après
la tenue en croire qu'on peut attendre
les grands desseins des départs nous
fait chuter le trio
et ça
c'est un grand monsieur nîmes l'abri
c'est ça ouais mais creuse
sabo n'diaye qui est l'un des plus
grands dramaturges
je
n'aime pas trop parler de moi
être sélectionné au bout de vingt années
de travail dans ma chronique comme seul
comme ingérable pour une résidence
d'écriture à avignon mais ces belles
années de travail pour que je puisse un
jour peut-être commencer à voir un petit
peu plus que j'essaie de faire
humblement dans mon petit
la vie les lectures et rencontres ont
rempli que il est nécessaire de ne
jamais perdre sa capacité enfants à être
émerveillés par l'incident inattendu
connaissait cette chanson de mal
mehal fallu beaucoup de talent pour être
vieux centaine d'adultes
il est crucial de chercher sa voie sans
confort désiré en restant en vie et
avidité
parce que
j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
confondre les deux dans ma vie j'ai dû
du lib aux portes du personnel nous
inquiète énormément dans la vie les
livres sont des fenêtres ouvertes sur
l'inconnu sur ce que vous n'avez pas à
portée de main qui nous donne tellement
d'enseignement et dans la ligue arabe
vous avez énormément exemple comment
tout ceci en vingt ans qu'il est vital
de puiser son énergie pour le plaisir et
sa force olemps bâti
c'est barack obama qui tout en disant on
peut les etats-unis aujourd'hui en
déficit de compétences à 10 kilos en une
année qui cite en pâtit c'est les deux
qui font l'homme c'est le bien et le
lien merci